The best way to sound like you know what you're talking about...
...is to know what you're talking about.
Once you've achieved this, approaching confidence as a desired goal...
...has much to do with cognitive anxiety, psyching yourself out.
The first thing you want to do is to convince yourself that you're a confident person.
Now this may sound cheesy at times,...
...but telling yourself over and over again that you are who you want to become,...
...that you don't even want to become that because you already are, is invaluable.
Driving to the event, start talking to yourself.
Finish the sentence, "I am confident."
"I'm composed."
"I'm excited to be here."
"I'm compassionate for my audience."
Telling yourself these things over and over again will convince yourself of that.
Are you asking yourself, "Why am I not confident?"
Because your brain is gonna come up with an answer.
Instead of asking yourself, "Why am I not confident?", tell yourself that you are.
Literally repeat, "I'm confident."
"I'm composed."
"I'm excited to be here."
"I will benefit my audience."